yep January being January which is not
the most exciting movie mom I'm gonna go
ahead and talk about a couple of shows
that just cross my path i binge them i
enjoy them and i was like eh you should
probably know about it i have enjoyment
i have concerns going forward but
there's a lot to talk about let's do it
[Music]
consonants are the man in the high
castle is an Amazon Prime series it's
based on a book by philip k dick i don't
know how much of the book the shows
based on but for the show it's an
alternate 1960s America in which America
and the Allies lost World War two which
lends itself to some interesting stuff
and the show does touch on interesting
stuff because not just that it wouldn't
just be Nazis running everything there
was the Empire of Japan what are they
doing they also own a bit of America and
you see that from the intro the intro to
this show is a brilliant intro I love
the song but I also love the visuals the
visuals tell you everything you need to
know you see how the attack happened you
see the map you see what the Nazis owned
what Japan on it's great if a show can
use his intro to tell you something
about the show Game of Thrones does that
every episode so right there the show
brought me on from it's in trouble where
it really shines is the fact that this
is it feels like a lived-in world I feel
like this show really does show what
would have happened had the Nazis won
let's talk about rufus sewell though
he's the one where I was just like this
guy's scary
he plays oboe group and feel that is a
word and I rank among the Nazis Open Cup
and fear but at a point you realize his
name is over group and feared John Smith
is to does not have a German accent he
was an American who was like well you
guys took cover and well call me a
survivor but I work for you now which is
another element of this feeling like a
lived-in world's not like Germans came
over and now the Americans are not Nazis
and it's 20 years later so the racism
and the whole Aryan race superiority
it's so ingrained in their culture
it's not even said with animosity it
just makes it feel so concrete and
established in that world it starts to
make you think that's very scary that
the Nazis had a fighting chance in World
War two to possibly rule the world you
know the powers of the world maybe they
didn't I imagine is gonna be some
commenters they didn't actually hold a
chance they just go with it and
the intrigue of this show is solidified
and you trying to figure out what these
films are there are films out there it
looks like news footage of some sort
that a lot of people want that shows the
Nazis losing World War two where do they
come from what are they is this all
propaganda
season one you're kind of brought on to
the art there's a world of the
resistance or the Nazis or German Nazis
or American Nazis and there's the
Japanese Empire alright hold on kaori
Hiroyuki Takaya I butcher that didn't I
hope not point is Shang Tsung is the man
but he's a genuinely good dude and
that's also what I like about this there
are good people among the ranks of
oppressors and there are also shitty
people among the
pressed and that's just human right
there I mean granted left so on the Nazi
slide the Reich doesn't really lend
itself to Nazis being able to be too
empathetic and carrying out that empathy
without them becoming enemies of the
state does not mean it's impossible for
someone who's in the Reich to possibly
surprise someone the show starts to slip
at a point when some of the site arcs
start to be useless in season two I love
the dude who owns that shop but
generally speaking his Ark is useless
and then the scary people who were
villains in season one become ultimately
anti-heroes on one hand I see why they
did it on the other hand you do take
away a villain and you can say well the
Nazi Reich as a whole is a villain you
don't need a person to be a villain but
it kind of reminded me of Deadwood howl
in episode 1 Al Swearengen was straight
up the villains and this time went on he
was an antihero same thing and there are
a couple of other things that for me
kind of trip season two ups where
they're going to season three I'm kind
of concerned about excited and concerned
I'm gonna get to that in a second but in
the end I will say the man in the high
castle is very intriguing it's an
interesting looking glass world into our
world if the Nazis had won it just it
makes you think I love a show that makes
me think now I'm gonna get into spoilers
in three two one
you've been warned here we go a big
mistake I think the show did in season
two is the first episode of season two
we meet the man in the high castle and
you find out the films were actually yes
it's multiverse they're dealing with the
multiverse which is the fact that it is
a lookingglass world in a hypothetical
world where the Nazis won World War two
that in and of itself tells you it is a
multiverse thing every show or movie
that shows a world that isn't actually
part of your history it's a multiverse
peak of some sort but when things start
to cross over from world to world then
it becomes a multiverse show that it
becomes kind of a sci-fi show the show
gave you way too many answers to sue the
intrigue of what the film was I love
that but the fact that I have the answer
and the fact that it looks like season
three is going to full multiverse route
kind of takes away from the social
commentary that was man in the high
castle for me it was a fascinating
morbid well executed scenario of seeing
America annexed into the write the war
has been long done we are living in Nazi
society that's what hooked me on the
show for the first time I think ever I'm
gonna say this about a piece of
entertainment it was never about the
multiverse for me it's about that and it
showed how rufus sewell said is it
Sewell or Sue Ellen I don't know point
is the guy who plays obergruppenführer
was saying in an interview it was like
it shows how people have an ability to
just go with
it's true if the Nazis had won the war
and they had come to America and annexed
our country into their Reich we would
just kind of go with it we would like to
think we'd fight tooth and nail but we
just wouldn't if they got the bomb and
dropped it on Washington DC we'd be like
okay
laying down arms now it looks like in
season three that promo they ran in
comic-con I believe it was comic-con
it looks like the Nazis have found out
about this multiverse and they're gonna
try to perfect the technology it's no
longer about the fact that Nazis run
everything
it's a multiverse show about someone
trying to breach through the multiverse
at that point the show kind of becomes
something like fringe and I really
enjoyed fringe but I have seen fringe
where as the man in the high castle
didn't feel like sci-fi before credit
there is a character in season two who
does spend the entirety of season two
crossing over and then spending his time
in our world the alternate world - their
world so right there the whole
multiverse crossing over thing that's
not a thing that's just out of the blue
that they're gonna do for season three
it was in season two it's the execution
right there it just felt out of place
for me however only fair to touch on the
guy from Nagasaki who is from our world
who crossed over into their world and
they did use it to bring us some
perspective was easy to say well our
worlds the good world in the Nazi world
world that's the bad world but someone
from Japan and especially that time in
Japan I'm sure they would prefer the
world where two nuclear warheads were
not dropped on their country I don't
know call it a leap so it can be used
for perspective it can waste some time I
hope they do it right however I take
heart in believing at least that the
useless characters and the useless side
arcs I believe they're done you just
kind of move on and focus up the plot
those are my thoughts on the man in the
high castle guys those are my concerns I
enjoy the man in the high castle those
my thoughts going forward I hope my
fears are exaggerated they're going the
multiverse route I just hope they keep
that which intrigues me about the show
thus far and I hope they stop having
useless side arc but it really is
enjoyable watch season one at least if
you're intrigued enough to watch season
two watch that too but the man in the
high castle have you seen it what did
you think about it whatever you thought
comment below let me know and as always
if you liked what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
[Music]